[Applause]
so
sometimes i get angry and it took me
many years to be able to say
just those words in my work
sometimes my body thrums i'm so enraged
but no matter how justified my anger has
been
throughout my life i've always been led
to understand
that my anger is an exaggeration a
misrepresentation
that it will make me rude and unlikable
mainly as a girl i learned as a girl
that anger is an emotion better left
entirely unvoiced
think about my mother for a minute when
i was 15 i came home from school one day
and she was standing on a long veranda
outside of our kitchen
holding a giant stack of plates imagine
how dumbfounded i was when she started
to throw them
like frisbees into the hot humid air
when every single plate had shattered
into thousands of pieces
on the hill below she walked back in and
she said to me cheerfully
how was your day
now you can see you can see how a child
would look at an incident like this and
think that anger
is silent and isolating destructive and
even frightening
especially though when the person who's
angry
is a girl or a woman the question is why
anger is a human emotion neither good
nor bad
it is actually a signal emotion it warns
us of indignity threat
insult and harm and yet in culture after
culture
anger is reserved as the moral property
of boys and men
now to be sure there are differences so
in the united states for example an
angry black man is viewed as a a
criminal
but an angry white man has civic virtue
regardless of where we are however the
emotion is gendered
and so we teach children to disdain
anger in girls and women and we grow up
to be
adults that penalize it
so what if we didn't do that what if we
didn't sever
anger from femininity because severing
anger from femininity means we sever
girls and women
from the emotion that best protects us
from injustice
what if instead we thought about
developing emotional competence
for boys and girls the fact is we still
remarkably socialize children in very
binary and oppositional ways
boys are held to absurd rigid norms of
masculinity
told to sort of renounce the feminine
emotionality of sadness or fair
and to embrace aggression and anger as
markers of real manhood
on the other hand girls learn to be
deferential
and anger is incompatible with deference
in the same way that we learn to cross
our legs
and tame our hair we learn to bite our
tongues and swallow our pride
what happens too often is that for all
of us
indignity becomes imminent in our
notions of femininity
there's a long personal and political
tale
to that bifurcation in anger
we go from being spoiled princesses and
hormonal teens
to high maintenance women and shrill
ugly nags we have flavors though pick
your flavor
are you a spicy hot latina when you're
mad
or a sad asian girl an angry black woman
or a crazy white one
you can pick but in fact the effect is
that when we say what's important to us
which is what anger is conveying
people are more likely to get angry at
us for being angry
whether we're at home or in school or at
work
or in a political arena anger confirms
masculinity
and it confounds femininity so men are
rewarded
for displaying it and women are
penalized for doing the same
this puts us at an enormous disadvantage
particularly when we have to defend
ourselves and our own interests
if we're faced with a threatening street
harasser a predatory employer
a sexist racist classmate our brains
are screaming are you kidding me
and our mouths say i'm sorry what
right and it's conflicting
because the anger gets all tangled up
with the anxiety and the fear and the
risk and retaliation if you ask women
what they fear the most in response to
their anger
they don't say violence they say mockery
think about what that means
if you have multiple marginalized
identities it's not just mockery
if you defend yourself if you put a
stake in the ground
there can be dire consequences now we
reproduce these patterns
not in big bold and blunt ways but in
the
everyday banality of life
when my daughter was in preschool every
single morning
she built an elaborate castle ribbons
and blocks and
every single morning the same boy
knocked it down gleefully
his parents were there but they never
intervened before the fact
they were happy to provide platitudes
afterwards
boys will be boys it's so tempting
he just couldn't help himself i did
what many girls and women learn to do i
preemptively kept the peace and i taught
my daughter to do the same thing
she used her words she tried to gently
body block him
she moved where she was building in the
classroom to no effect
so i and the other adults mutually
constructed
a particular male entitlement he could
run rampant and control the environment
and she kept her feelings to herself and
worked around his needs
we failed both of them by not giving her
anger the uptake and
resolution that it deserved now that's a
microcosm
of a much bigger problem because
culturally
worldwide we preference
the performance of masculinity and the
power and privilege that come with that
performance
over the rights and needs and words of
children and women
so it will come as absolutely no
surprise probably to the people in this
room
that women report being angrier
in more sustained ways and with more
intensity than men do
some of that comes from the fact that
we're socialized to ruminate to keep it
to ourselves and mullet over
but we also have to find socially
palatable ways
to express the intensity of emotion that
we have
and the awareness that it brings of our
precarity
so we do several things if men knew
how often women were filled with white
hot rage when we cried
they would be staggered
we use minimizing language we're
frustrated no really it's okay
self-objectify and lose the ability to
even recognize the physiological
changes that indicate anger
mainly though we get sick
anger has now been implicated in a whole
array of illnesses that are casually
dismissed
as women's illnesses higher rates of
chronic pain
autoimmune disorders disordered eating
mental distress anxiety self-harm
depression
anger affects our immune systems our
cardiovascular systems
some studies even indicate that it
affects mortality rates
particularly in black women with cancer
i am sick and tired of the women i know
being sick and tired
our anger brings great discomfort
and the conflict comes because it's our
role
to bring comfort there is anger that's
acceptable we can be angry
when we stay in our lanes and buttress a
status quo
as mothers or teachers we can be mad
but we can't be angry about the
tremendous costs
of nurturing we can be angry at our
mothers
let's say as teenagers patriarchal rules
and regulations
we don't blame systems we blame them we
can be angry at other women
because who doesn't love a good cat
fight
and we can be angry at men with lower
status
in an expressive hierarchy that supports
racism or xenophobia
but we have an enormous power in this
because
feelings are the purview of our
authority
and people are uncomfortable with our
anger
we should be making people comfortable
with the discomfort they feel
when women say no unapologetically
we can take emotions and think in terms
of competence
and not gender people who are able to
process their anger
and make meaning from it are more
creative
more optimistic they have more intimacy
they're better problem solvers
they have greater political efficacy
now i'm a woman writing about women and
feelings
so very few men with power are going to
take what i'm saying
seriously as a matter of politics
we think of politics and anger in terms
of the contempt and disdain
and and fury that are feeding a rise of
macho fascism in the world
but if it's that poison it's also the
antidote
we have an anger of hope and we see it
every single day
in the resistant anger of women and
marginalized people
it's related to compassion and empathy
and love and we should recognize that
anger
as well the issue
is that societies that don't respect
women's anger don't respect women
the real danger of our anger isn't that
it will break bonds
or plates it's that it
exactly shows how seriously we take
ourselves
and we expect other people to take us
seriously as well
when that happens chances are very good
that women will be able to smile
when they want to
thank you
you